with season nine just around the corner
i found myself recently going over old
scripts on the previous four manhunts
just to bring myself up to speed
so because it's been a little while
since these first came out and there
were a lot of people who didn't actually
play through them i thought i would
throw together the somewhat tweaked
story compilation of the first four
manhunts
this will be around two hours long so
for those of you who keep telling me
that you like to fall asleep to my
monotone voice this video is for you
[Music]
[Music]
with the fall of the infamous rogue
agent aaron kina a new line of rogue
agents were put into action to fulfill
what he calls his legacy
with the first manhunt now concluded
what exactly were they trying to achieve
molly henderson callsign jupiter was
recruited by the division after proving
herself in the private sector as a
security consultant
leaning on a four-year military
background jupiter excelled in combat
and physical training exercises
however she was noted as a potential
risk due to her past involvement in
militant activism
she had been part of a group that was
later involved in the kidnapping and
assault of a prominent business
executive
nevertheless nothing could ever be tied
to her as she claimed to have left the
group by the time the incident
in all psychological evaluations
supported this claim
jupiter was activated as part of the
division's first wave and it was at this
time that she first met aaron kina
her status was changed to rogue after an
incident in the new york quarantine zone
where two jtf officers were killed
jupiter has since been linked to the
murders of at least 15 jtf officers
some time after this kena returned to
new york he approached jupiter and had
her establish a team for a future attack
that will be carried out in washington
dc
we need to go now is our extraction set
i got a boat waiting for you and your
team in jamaica bay are you sure you
can't take the lead on this mission your
team is perfect you work well together
and i know i can trust you to handle
things in washington really wish you
were coming with us i can't leave new
york now there's too much at stake
besides my team didn't really play well
with others
that's fair still who could use more
bodies just in case things go sideways
don't worry i won't let you go without
backup conway's left you a present
you're gonna like it
just don't forget to feed them
one of the first agents that jupiter got
in contact with was ryan chang
mutual friend thought we might be able
to help each other out
this is a secure channel
secure enough
what's your name you want a call sign
for this op
seem smart
plants animals zodiac
went to the planetarium last week
always been partial to mercury fine
mercury
names jupiter nice to meet you
is it true you're working with the
cleaners i've got access but connolly
uranus is their real leader
mars brought us together they're
efficient
if i had a team like that here we could
have eradicated the outcasts in a couple
of weeks
that's the goal
mercury was recruited by the division
from the military after earning a silver
star in afghanistan
he left the military and became a
marketing manager for a tactical
equipment company
mercury was activated as part of the
division's second wave but was marked as
rogue after reportedly torturing and
executing prisoners
he has been described as intelligent and
calculating with a tendency for violent
outbursts
peer reviews regularly described him as
being a bit difficult to work with
earlier on mercury can be heard arguing
with kelso regarding the loading of
supplies into a cargo plane
we need to finish getting those supplies
ready for transport
this is a mistake
the shipment goes out tonight
we need this gear we have enough
supplies we're just moving the surplus
if the hyenas or the true sons find out
about this stockpile if the true suns
come for us we will need these weapons
to defend ourselves
you're a good agent ryan but i need you
to help me out and just
finish the job we don't have time to
argue about this the plane's already on
its way
mercury felt these supplies would be
better used to help in the fight against
the true suns and the hyenas
the cargo plane in question would later
crash onto roosevelt island
not long after this incident mercury was
marked as road
chadwick brandon callsign neptune was a
flight engineer at the time of
recruitment
and was activated as part of the
division's first wave
his job was to contain the civil unrest
in the early days and to secure the
midtown quarantine zone
not long after activation he ran into
another agent called mike
the two men started working together as
a team forming a tight bond
during his time with the shd neptune set
up a lot of the critical infrastructure
at the base of operations including a
set of backup generators that could
guarantee stable power and
communications
however when the retreat was called in
the quarantine zone neptune and mike
were left surrounded by rioters and no
jtf to support them
while under heavy fire mike was gunned
down while neptune only just managed to
escape
dismayed by the loss of his partner and
close friend neptune held a grudge
towards the jtf
went on to sabotage the generators that
he helped build in the base of
operations and turned killing eight jtf
staff members and injuring 23 more
after that neptune disappeared
this is division agent chadwick brandon
reporting from midtown manhattan
final midtown sid rep
the jtf left us behind
we lost i don't know how many agents
because of it
people who relied on the jtf support but
never got it
we were supposed to tackle this together
but when the [ __ ] hit the fan it was
clear we were on our own
mike died because of them we ran into
each other when we first got activated
he worked well together i wasn't there
for him
no one was
and now i'll never see him again
we're not going to forget this
jupiter managed to track neptune down
and reached out to him they're looking
for you
let them come
you think you can handle it when a full
squad storms in and surrounds you
i'm not going down without a fight i'll
take some of them with me
you die they win
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore this world
can get [ __ ] for all i care
i know you're hurting
i'll leave you with your grief
if you're still alive and want to do
something you know where to find me we
can [ __ ] the world together
initially neptune refused but after had
been given a little more time to mourn
and think over it he got back in contact
with jupiter
lucy anders codenamed venus was a first
wave division agent
her status changed to rogue after she
abandoned the mission disappearing for
six weeks
investigations revealed that she had
established her own safe house and was
directly undermining the jtf's work by
claiming critical drops and supplies
destined for a jtf operations base
later on three division agents were
dispatched to retrieve the stolen
supplies
they managed to locate venus but two of
the agents were killed and the third was
seriously injured
this agent was able to survive and
record an eyewitness account of the
incident
merry masters aka saturn was an attorney
before she was recruited by the division
she was part of the first wave that was
released after the dollar flu first
struck
however like many before her she turned
rogue not long after
reports state that she shot down an
extraction helicopter in darkzone west
in washington dc killing two jtf pilots
and a division agent
the psychological evaluations indicate
signs of trust issues and a lack of
confidence in others
mercury this is jupiter come in
this is mercury
we're set
moving out tonight should be in your
solar system in a couple of days what
code
we're coming to your neck of the woods
should be there in a couple of days no
why didn't you just say that
we all set
yeah black tusk invaded the island but
local agents cleared them it doesn't
appear our cargo has been discovered we
should still be good to go
great you send me the coordinates
up and running yet
local test runs but not system wide
you should still be able to send direct
messages great
you need anything special
if your intel's correct we should have
everything we need from the crash
uranus is working on some new prototypes
specs are saved on the network hopefully
we'll be able to test some of them once
we get to roosevelt
looking forward to it
jupiter's team were preparing for the
mission
supplies have been stockpiled and were
being loaded into the safe house
one of these included a red package from
arakina
jupiter
we got a care package from keener a red
package
yeah i saw it
what do you want me to do with it
get rid of it i don't want anything to
do with that you sure
you saw what it could do at city hall
this is the leverage keener was talking
about
this isn't some kind of silver bullet
saturn
it's a [ __ ] bio weapon
we're doing this to eradicate a virus
not spread something even more dangerous
of course
you're right
i'll destroy it
just be careful
i don't want to find out you dropped it
and killed the whole team
don't worry i've got this under control
yeah that's what they all say
until they don't
this package contained kina's new super
virus that had been developed by
trinenko
but jupiter wanted nothing to do with
this
regardless of what keener had in mind
jupiter's mission was still the same to
remove the virus
to do what the jtf and the government
were incapable of doing themselves
she wasn't going to replace the dollar
flu with an even more deadly virus
before jupiter's team could roll out she
needed to ensure that their
communications and logistics would be
robust
she needed someone to stay behind and
hold the fort
when we leave
i need you to stay back on this one
you're kidding
look saturn you know i trust you
yeah
you're the best agent i've got
venus can be a little
unpredictable and neptune's barely
keeping it together can you blame him
no but that right there is why i need
you here
you care about people
i need you to make sure the operation is
secure
fine
what do you need
maintain the safe house keep calms open
in case we need anything
you take care of the eclipse
yeah
found a way to neutralize the dispersal
mechanism put in a hole blew it up and
buried the evidence
i knew i could count on you
next mission
you're with me in the field
jupiter couldn't trust venus or neptune
to stay on track saturn was the most
reliable option she had
all right here's the deal
i know you're conley's guys i know you
answered to her but until this operation
is over
you answer to me and my crew
i don't want to have any problems
we have a long journey and a hard road
ahead of us
but if we do this
if we get this right
we will be that much closer to
eradicating the disease once and for all
we have multiple reports of experiments
trying to weaponize the virus being
carried out with the blood of
asymptomatic carriers we need to
eliminate this threat
we're going to locate the lab samples
and these carriers to make sure the
green poison is destroyed once and for
all
their mission was to eradicate the green
poison
reports of experiments and weaponizing
meant they were to focus on locating
labs samples and carriers of the virus
and put an end to it once and for all
but with the introduction of the
cleaners to the team jupiter found
herself in an argument with venus
she expressed her concerns about working
with the fanatics and that she didn't
trust their intentions
in particular venus was having trouble
with the leader of cleaner backup
buckley
i can't work with buchanan or baker or
whatever the hell that guy's name is you
mean barkley
i can't understand anything he says in
that stupid [ __ ] mask
what's the problem
he doesn't respect me his team doesn't
respect me if they don't listen to me
they're gonna get us all killed
you're exaggerating
i'm not jupiter come on you know me
look i can talk to him but it's not
going to make him respect you
you want him to respect you
take care of it yourself
oh i'll take care of it i just needed
permission
jupiter told her that they needed the
backup and that she needed to find a way
of working with them or that maybe she
just wasn't suitable for the job at hand
so venus took it upon herself to rather
than reason with the guy to instead
shoot him
what the [ __ ] did you do
what
barkley's dead
you told me to take care of it so i took
care of it
i meant
talk to him not shoot him in the head
i did talk to him
he yelled at me and reached for his axe
my response was measured and appropriate
huh is that true
true enough
and now his team listens to me
so see i took care of it
you didn't take care of it
you were supposed to gain their respect
not their fear venus
they listen to you now because they're
afraid of you but as soon as they aren't
afraid
you messed up
i thought you were better than this
mercury
good to meet you jupiter
that was the trip
fine couple of rough patches had to put
out a couple of fires you know
the usual everything's set at the docks
we should be good
supplies are a little low need to send a
couple strike teams out for food water
and weapons but we've got plenty of
space and the boys are looking for fuel
you give me a list of what you need and
i can help you make those strike teams
you're good
i'm efficient
jupiter's team was now in dc
mercury initiated his attack on multiple
sites including the capitol building
lincoln memorial space administration hq
and air and space museum capturing a
number of the control points in between
while neptune focused on the western
side of dc
venus made moods in northeastern dc
capturing multiple sites of value in
downtown east federal triangle and
judiciary square
while saturn continued to hold down the
safe house in new york
one by one the division was able to
locate the rogue agents in dc
including saturn's whereabouts in lower
manhattan
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
eliminate them
this was happening jupiter was still
running point on the main mission
while team was being hunted down and
killed by the division jupiter was on
roosevelt island
she was securing a newly developed emp
technology from a cargo plane that had
crashed there some time ago
combined with vivian conley's technology
these new emp jammers were able to
neutralize all non-rogue shd tech and
completely removed an agent's armor
jupiter's goal was to capture this tech
get it operational and ship it out to
rogue agents nationwide
this would [ __ ] the remaining shd
agents around the country
the purpose of her team of agents and
the accompanying cleaners was to
distract the division while she prepared
roosevelt island
however the division reacted faster than
jupiter was prepared for
the agents managed to overwhelm the
rogues and push the cleaners back to the
island where jupiter was forced to make
a last stand
she ordered the cleaners to utilize all
available emp jammers to put a stop to
the fast approaching agents
but it was too late
the division pushed through the defenses
destroying the emps and found themselves
face to face with jupiter and eventually
after a long battle embarrassingly
longer than i'd like to admit the agents
put a stop to her plans killing her in
the process
accepted division this is a war you
can't win
keeler's legacy will live on
may be dead if it wasn't for you i won't
let you down
not again
[Music]
having technically already died once one
of kena's lieutenants from the division
one is back and more loyal to kena's
cause than ever
hornet kena's most trusted agent is
leading a sell of rogues to fulfill his
legacy
but who are they and what are they
planning
in the early days carter leroux
codenamed hornet had his entire career
path planned out for him by his parents
studying economics he was eventually
interning for the family firm
but after a short stint he felt
unsatisfied with this direction and
chose to sign up with the armed forces
hornet joined the army and was stationed
in djibouti africa
during this time he met future rogue
agent aaron kina and they quickly struck
up a friendship becoming close brothers
in arms
after he returned home family tensions
left hornet feeling alienated and alone
he was lost and unsure of what to do
with his life next
after everything he had seen he just
couldn't return to a desk job
however he managed to keep in touch with
kina who knew where he was coming from
and suggested he do something positive
with his life and sign up to the
division
keena put hornet in touch with division
recruiter elijah lee who quickly signed
him up due to his capabilities and
experience
what do you think about kadalarou
tina recommended him said they grew up
together grew up together
his file says he grew up in michigan
that's not exactly jersey looks like
they served together in djibouti figures
stick a bunch of guys in a room throw in
some guns and an existential threat and
the next thing you know they're all
reborn and calling each other brother it
says he volunteered for service that's
exactly what scares me
he's a thrill seeker
big game hunter former futures trader
sound familiar
what kind of person takes frequent trips
to zimbabwe to slaughter two-ton animals
after returning from a war zone a person
who isn't afraid of a challenge or a
person with a taste for killing he
follows the law plays by the rules wants
to say we can't use that we could do
with a few more people like him to
balance the books a little if we're
rubber stamping this guy you're
responsible for him if he starts hunting
again
however when kena turned rogue hornet
was the first agent to answer his call
with their history he would continue to
follow kena's every move
after the second wave was activated
division agents were called upon to
retrieve the russian virologist vitaly
trininko in the russian embassy
keena called upon hornet to secure
traneco before the division got to him
finding him locked up in a safe room
within the embassy hornet used a
breaching charge to blow open a wall
while the division were on the other
side of the safe room trying to talk the
way in
the division pursued but hornet managed
to extract the russian scientist in a
helicopter before they caught up to him
in an attempt to stall the agents
hornets stayed behind and engaged them
head-on
the division managed to overwhelm and
take him down
leaving him for dead the division moved
on to return the information they had
found on site to the base of operations
having been fed information from a man
on the inside kina made his way to the
russian consulate
outside he found hornet severely injured
and dying
kina brought him to laurie baker a rogue
agent and former army surgeon who
managed to bring him back from the brink
of death
i can't believe you came for me you
don't leave a brother in the field
especially not on foreign soil i lost
your ninja's research it's okay i failed
you forget the consulate
you survived you didn't fail me
this is just a setback i'd be dead if it
wasn't for you your heart stopped for a
couple of seconds so you were
technically dead
but termites good she brought you back
if you boys are done making out i'd
really like to move this location's not
secure can you walk i'll get it together
you're stronger than anyone could ever
know
and i know
you will do great things i won't let you
down
not again
this action only further enhanced
hornet's loyalty to kina becoming his
closest ally in the days to come
he vowed to do everything in his power
to help keener on his mission
working behind the scenes kinder
eventually resurfaced with a new
variation of the virus that started it
all
with some of his rogue agents he
attacked city hall in lower manhattan
while kena had the division's attention
he tasked hornet with getting to
washington dc and recruiting an army to
help with the cause
to help him get the job done kena
supplied him with a number of eclipse
virus samples that he could use to
persuade any likely candidates
ordnance set up for dc along with four
other rogue agents
consisting of termite titan luna and
huntsman
lori baker code named termite was
trained as an army surgeon and took part
in a number of military conflicts
overseas
she was eventually dismissed from the
military after failing to follow orders
told to retreat during an attack on a
hostile base in southern afghanistan
she instead opted to stay tending to a
group of wounded soldiers
but this impressed division recruiters
showing independence and the ability to
make difficult decisions in high stress
situations
she was recruited and trained as a first
wave division agent
once activated terma was tasked with
securing a quarantine center that was
set up by the government in new york
city
but after witnessing the effect of the
green poison she began to lose
confidence in the division's goal
believing that the only way to control
the spread was to eliminate the sick and
dying
what's her condition high fever and
abdominal pains move her to quarantine
her test results came back negative
she's clean it's not green poison we
can't take any chances the medical wing
is full we have people sleeping in
hallways and bathrooms it's like
an incubation chamber she can't stay
here i am not gambling with her life if
we put her in quarantine with her immune
system compromise she won't make it a
week and send her on her way
you can't keep admitting people off the
streets like this i don't take my orders
from the division
she's staying the time to start
listening was yesterday if you keep
insisting on making the wrong choices
i'll have to make the right ones for you
they're weak they won't survive we can't
just leave them i'm not suggesting we
leave them what are you suggesting do
you really need me to say it say it
it's over the more we fight it the
stronger it gets there's only one option
left you sound just like those people
out there burning this city to ash
we've seen this all before
viruses appear and spread but ultimately
they are defeated not this time
eventually the cleaners arrived to
cleanse the hospital
seeing this as an opportunity termite
disavowed the division
instead of holding off the attack she
killed a number of division agents and
jtf
allowing the cleaners to break through
the defense
in turn killing all patients and staff
on site
i'm impressed i don't have time for your
[ __ ] keener that takes particularly
strong or broken person to facilitate
mass euthanasia
you don't strike me as broken
you understand what we're up against
listen if you're trying to get me to
repopulate the earth with you you're
barking up the wrong tree oh god no
children are for people with free time
and our time is limited if we don't do
something about it you have to think
about what kind of legacy you want to
leave you've got something in mind no i
got a plan
and i just
need to know if you're committed give me
the elevator pitch and i'll tell you
we're going to eradicate the weak
i'm in
kenya saw this as an opportunity to
recruit another agent to the cause
termite would later be responsible for
nursing hornet back to health before
eventually heading off to washington dc
on the recruitment mission
tegan silva codenamed luna comes from
the security industry where she's
extensive experience
she was working for the state department
in washington dc when she was activated
her role was involved with closely
monitoring internal
operations but when president ellis
ordered the jtf's withdrawal from the
dark zone in new york she began to lose
faith in the government's ability to
control the situation
you hear about new york there is a
massive outbreak in quarantine division
agents have been activated to assist the
jtf in regaining control of the city
yeah i heard the jtf pulled out [ __ ]
decided they lost enough people built a
wall locked it down walled off the sick
hostiles
any agent foolish enough to stay behind
they can't do that they can't just leave
agents to die apparently they can we
have to do something
we have to stop them who gave the order
ellis
it's too late gave the order an hour ago
rumor is jtf moved out and the cleaners
moved in they're currently sterilizing
the area
some time later after keena went rogue
and started recruiting ilani kelso
brought luna some encrypted echoes to
reconstruct
these have been sent over by the
division in new york
hey tegan you busy nope i've got time i
need you to work on some echoes for me
you got the base data i can make you an
echo no no i don't need you to make me
an echo i need you to fix them okay you
have the files got a data transfer from
an agent in new york li lao love
something like that she's been
collecting encrypted echoes was hoping
that maybe one of our techs could find
anything to help her identify or locate
these rogues i'll do what i can tegan
you're the best
although luna was tasked with tracking
the rogue agents down she found herself
listening to a man who shared her views
becoming a believer in kina's vision for
the future she managed to create a
connection to the rogue network
frequency that he was using
[Music]
vanguard
luna
how did you get on this line
your encryption isn't bad but i cracked
it in maybe 20 minutes
you're lucky elani brought me your
echoes to crack
i've been listening
i want to help
how do i know i can trust you well
you'll have to take my word for it for
now that's all i've got words mean
nothing without actions what can you
offer you've seen what i can do
the division still thinks i'm one of
them so you want to be my
man on the inside i do sir
i think it's criminal what they did to
you
no one can realistically think that the
way out of this crisis is to save what
remains i'm glad you understand what
we're trying to do here
there's only one way to end tyranny
anarchy you're a smart cookie
luna had become keen as agent on the
inside of the division and was able to
feed him intel allowing him to continue
to be several steps ahead of them
it was luna that informed keener of the
division's operation to secure vitaly
trinenko at the russian consulate
this gave keener the opportunity to
react and warn hornet of their approach
this warning however would have finally
been flagged as a rogue agent
she would be reassigned to a position of
surveillance for kina's operation
elijah lee code named huntsman worked in
the bomb disposal unit in afghanistan
over time he earned a silver star for
bravery
however after tripping an explosive
device one day he was given an honorable
discharge and spent a year undergoing
physical therapy for his injuries
later on he was hired by the division as
a recruiter in fact he was the one
responsible for hiring both kinah and
hornet
when the situation arose and the first
wave of agents were activated huntsman
used the opportunity to join them out in
the field as an agent
but over time like many before him he
lost faith in the division's ability to
get on top of the situation
and with the deployment of the last man
battalion he saw them as the ones who
would be able to get on top of the
anarchy that was starting to unfold
i just want you to understand one thing
charles i'm not doing this because i
think the division was a mistake
i'm doing this because the division is
failing
right now the last man battalion has the
best chance to take control of this [ __ ]
show
besides i always look good in winter
camo
eventually the division took down the
last man battalion leader charles bliss
and after his death huntsman was left
not knowing what to do lost
of course thanks to luna's intel keenan
knew all about his situation and offered
him a job
i was sorry to hear about bliss
charles was a good man a good man don't
make it very far in this world what do
you want keener to give you a job i've
got a job without bliss your buddies
won't stick around
they'll join the next pmc to come along
and promise them a hot meal you know i'm
not like that i do
you're committed you're loyal
once you make a decision you stick with
it until you decide to abandon it
only two things you've ever quit of the
division and that copper spaniel kept
pissing on your carpet [ __ ] that dog and
the ex-wife he rode in on
that's her problem now this was her
problem
karen died last week i guess there's a
silver lining
where are you getting your intel i got
someone in dc
luna's got her ear to the ground and an
eye in the sky say hi hey huntsman who
the [ __ ] is huntsman
you are
if you're ready
jason barnes codenamed titan spent 10
years as a firefighter before gaining a
diploma in wildland fire science and
training as a smoke jumper
after years of witnessing the
destruction of nature he became an
outspoken environmentalist
he was noticed by the division after he
survived for six days stuck in a
wildland fire that took the lives of the
rest of his unit
due to quickly spreading fires and city
parks titan was recruited and then
quickly activated during the second wave
he didn't actually receive any formal
division
we're training the second wave we need
you in new york is it as bad as they say
it is it's worse
and it's not just the green poison
that's spreading we've got paranoid
residents burning everything in sight
it's raining ash and the fire
department's overwhelmed
there's no way inside unless you go in
from the top
think you can handle it i can handle it
what do you need from me you'll drop
down over central park we need you to
coordinate the trench build along the
perimeter what do you need from us a
pretty orange watch you're easy to
please just send a helo and briefly on
the way thank you
and welcome to the division agent
after being treated for severe smoke
inhalation he was taken to a sarah
hospital where he's surrounded by
victims of the green poison
he saw firsthand the destruction caused
by the virus
although titan was injured he refused to
stay in the hospital
even with a nurse trying to stop him
titan got as far away from there as
possible
know you're only doing what you think is
right
and in some way i admire that
truth is
i don't understand what you're fighting
for and i don't think you do either you
call this a crisis
you think that death is a tragedy
but the real tragedy is how our innate
desire for survival overshadows our
appreciation for life
this is an opportunity
how much devastation will it take to
realize that
perhaps we
are the poison
maybe it's time to accept our punishment
and
let nature decide
what's best for the world
this experience led him to question
everything that they were doing
as a true eco-terrorist he began
wondering if this whole thing was
nature's way of trying to
survive jason barnes
the agent with no official division
training
congratulations on the promotion
seems like you're smarter than the rest
of us you didn't call to give me
compliments keener i
liked your manifesto thought i'd share
my enthusiasm
you've got it all wrong sooner or later
we're all gonna die
i guess the real question is
what do you want to leave behind that's
the point i don't want to leave anything
behind
well not even a legacy
green poison will run its course and
then the same people who trashed this
planet will try to rebuild it and end up
destroying it for good
but with a little intervention
you could change that future
even though the goals were different the
methods of getting there were the same
titan agreed to join keener in his
rogues and stop humanity from continuing
down the same path they were headed
before the outbreak
once in dc hornet set forth with
recruiting
he saw the outcasts as good place to
start since they were currently
leaderless and in need of a purpose
but they aren't exactly friendly to
strangers
however he had a different way of
getting their attention
what the hell happened here you think it
was the true sons it's not like them
this was chemical maybe it was green
poison impossible people don't just drop
dead like that stay away from that smoke
it's called eclipse don't [ __ ] move
careful his watch is red relax
i keep my eyes open the jtf had been
causing you trouble thought i'd ease
that burden for you besides i needed to
get your attention somehow your people
aren't too friendly to strangers
we should kill them i wouldn't advise
that fear green poison is the only real
weapon you have and that won't last much
longer with antivirals starting to
circulate you've seen what the eclipse
virus is capable of and i've got plenty
to go around
it was around this time that the
division had caught up to kina and after
chasing clues around southern manhattan
they eventually faced off of them on
liberty island
where it was finally brought down and
eliminated
this lead to in-house fighting between
huntsman and hornet
with huntsman eager to take over where
kina left off and hornet kena's closest
ally having vowed to keep things on
track
hornet
who died and put you in charge [ __ ] you
huntsman a real leader knows how to work
through his grief without lashing out at
others sure
you trying to make this power play now
that's just perfect
do you think you're half as smart as he
was oh i don't think i know and face it
kid you're not ready to leave this up
why don't you let the adults handle this
one keener left me in charge
he trusted me with the eclipse recipe
you're not a leader
you're just running around stinging my
ass and you're just a creepy ass spider
hiding in the corner too small and
chicken [ __ ] to do anything regardless
of how poisonous your bite may be you've
been working on that for a while now kid
haven't you fallen or get the [ __ ] out
each one of hornet's team of rogue
agents split up to cover more ground in
dc
termites set off attacking multiple
sites including bank headquarters the
federal emergency bunker manning
national zoo and camp white oak
while titan focused on the western side
of dc including the pentagon and darpa
labs
huntsman made moves in southeastern dc
capturing multiple sites of value in
judiciary square federal triangle south
west and east mall
while luna continued to run surveillance
from safe house in new york
one by one the division was able to
locate the rogue agents in dc including
luna's whereabouts in lower manhattan
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
take them down
while all of this was happening hornet
was a tidal basin with his new army of
outcasts
as burkina's instructions he'd been busy
producing stockpiles of the eclipse
virus and was getting ready to move out
the loss of his team of rogues meant
that the division was quickly able to
locate him
the division assaulted the compound only
slowing down to avoid the pockets of
eclipse virus that horner had released
across the site in an attempt to block
and kill the agents
after fighting through waves of outcast
forces the division managed to destroy
the virus supplies
while frantically loading the remaining
supplies onto the hovercraft hornet and
his outcasts were attempting to escape
before the division were able to reach
them
but the agents caught up to him
quickly dealing to the outcasts and
destroying the samples on board
hornet launched an attack on the
division
however they proved too much
and were able to bring him down and
eliminate him
this time for good
time and time again the black tusks have
been hindering the strategic homeland
divisions attempts at regaining control
of the nation's capital
so it's finally time to remove the btsu
leader from the equation
but why did he suddenly have a bunch of
ex-division agents working with him
and what was with that bloody hunter
that kept smacking me in the back of the
head while my back was turned
barden schaefer is the leader of the
black tusk specialist unit the btsu
he comes from a family with a proud
traditional and long line of military
service
and at the age of 19 dropped out of
college and enlisted in the army
there he took no time at all and showing
an exceptionally high degree of skill
which resulted in a swift and steady
rise through the ranks
baden served multiple tours of iraq and
afghanistan
he quickly became known for his highly
tactical way of assessing situations and
having the ability to eliminate targets
with extreme efficiency
later he was assigned to a special
forces unit where he was involved in a
number of dark ops before eventually
being approached by the black tusk
highly respected among his colleagues it
wasn't long before he was given the role
of specialist unit leader
he was given the task of gaining control
of washington dc so his employers could
establish a new government
biden legitimately believes he is a true
patriot and that everything he's doing
is for the betterment of the country
the division only answers to the
president but now that he has joined
with the btsu they no longer listen to
him so they're traitors
in his eyes the existing government is
corrupt and the division are nothing
more than a rogue agency
after the division discovered agent lau
and coswelt had teamed up with baden
they realized that his threat level was
only increasing regardless of how many
of his ops that they were putting a stop
to
they needed to target the man himself
but barden had been busy and was
recruiting other division agents too
ones who had had a change of heart and
had turned their back on the shd
some of these rogues included shade
wraith dusk
and belfry
maliero codenamed shade was a parole
officer in new york city
and a large number of the people she
dealt with were released from rikers
island
after she was activated as part of the
second wave in new york city she became
aware of the horrific event that was
about to unfold when the call was made
to abandon the prisoners and leave them
to starve
she knew these people and what they were
capable of achieving
just because they are prisoners they
shouldn't be left to slowly die
it would be kinder just to shoot them
she had witnessed these people do great
things after their time incarcerated
some of them were good people that had
simply found themselves in the wrong
situations
some had been locked up for reasonably
minor offences and were only serving a
term of 12 months or less
and some of them hadn't even been
convicted yet
often these were the people who couldn't
afford bail who were awaiting trial
not long after james dragoff the
division agent who'd killed the warden
on rikers island and then freed the
prisoners approached her
he asked for her assistance in
supporting his family of rikers
she obliged and began working alongside
him in turn marking her as a rogue agent
prior to joining dragoff she had worked
closely with feylau and after dragoff's
death they introduced her to barden
schaefer
you'll get the delivery tomorrow thanks
shafer you'll get that destabilization
you're looking for that's not the goal
shade we'll keep the division busy so
you can do whatever high-level espionage
it is you need to do if you're so smart
why the hell are you running with the
rikers you want to be on the winning
side right i want to be on the right
side
okay sure
not overly convinced by baden's claims
that he was fighting for the side that
was right she agreed to support him in
exchange for supplies that iraq is
desperately needed
however gossip quickly started to spread
through the riker ranks about how she
was working with baden schaefer
delivery tomorrow get a recovery team
together we get coordinates we're just
hoping for some [ __ ] to fall out of the
sky we'll get them an hour before the
drop safer that way [ __ ] i was joking
i heard you talking to schaefer you
forget that name okay stop playing
you know what happens to people who play
with me sorry boss not today
sueko tanagi codenamed wraith was a
logistics officer in the u.s army after
she left the armed forces she returned
home to atlanta and found a job in her
field of expertise and started working
as a logistics officer for a large
transportation company
later on she was recruited by the
division and using the skills of her
trade she was activated to help keep
sarah's supply lines operational at a
crucial point where the global economy
was starting to collapse
however at the same time she was
approached by the black tusk
she decided that this was the perfect
opportunity and went on to exploit and
control supply to both the us government
and the global corporation that is
behind the black tusk
wraith is an opportunist and has no
problem working both sides in order to
benefit herself
she is arrogant narcissistic and gutsy
enough to exploit two of the largest
most powerful organizations around
she is all about working the system
whether it be corporations or people
and when it comes to the hyenas they are
weak-minded substance abusers constantly
trying to get their next fix
and she's the one capable of fulfilling
this need
in turn making them her puppets
she is very good at getting what she
wants
not long after going rogue her and baden
made contact
baden knew that wraith and the hyenas
would become a valuable asset in the
days to come so he was eager to win her
over in order for her to assist in the
operation
lynette edwards codenamed dusk was a
third generation marine
she had chosen to follow in her family's
tradition and pursue a military career
however it was her father that put in a
recommendation to the shd
she was recruited shortly after her
first tour of duty
dusk was activated in washington dc but
it didn't take long for her to come to
the conclusion that the institution was
corrupt
in fact she was finding herself more and
more aligned with the true son's way of
thinking than the shd
seeing all the tragedy caused by the
virus and how overwhelmed the jtf had
become dusk started losing faith in the
division's ability to save washington dc
she quickly came to the conclusion that
more drastic actions needed to be taken
to ensure their survival
as a strong believer in the need for
proper authority and discipline in her
eyes the true sons were the only ones
with a realistic and viable solution to
the situation
she eventually decided that enough was
enough she turned rogue and joined up
with the true sons
when the true sun's leader antoine
ridgeway was eventually hunted down and
killed by the division dusk went on to
continue ridgway's work with a group of
true sons who were devoted to his cause
dusk is loyal patriotic and cares
greatly for comrades
unfortunately the attacks had left them
weakened and short on supplies
we need anything running low on rations
bullets grenades and men so just
everything pretty much how long can we
hold out on the current stockpile a week
maybe more if we stop feeding the
privates i'll start eating rats before
we stop feeding our men
that's how you get a mutiny
she would do whatever it took to help a
new family
even if it meant making a deal with the
devil
dusk would use a contacts to gain a
connection within the black tusk and
offer a trade in return for food water
and weapons
skylar williams code name belfry served
in the u.s army and was eventually
approached by the shd and recruited as
an agent
after retiring from the army he went on
to become a local police officer in a
predominantly residential commuter town
following the outbreak he was activated
in his home state of maryland but was
stationed at the washington dc sierra
camp in dz south
but unfortunately it was his experience
in these camps that would change his
allegiance
he witnessed the insufficiently tested
chemical called dc62 being pushed into
these camps by the people who are
supposed to be protecting them
belfry watch countless families succumb
to this lethal yellow powder
gasping for air clawing frantically at
their throats while the toxic fumes burn
their lungs causing asphyxiation and
ultimately their death
questioning his role as a division agent
feeling partially responsible and
equally helpless at the same time
he left his post in turn being flagged
as rogue
eventually he made contact with baden
where he would offer his assistance in
exchange for supplies
he was working to help other victims of
these quarantine camps
the outcasts
congratulations lao you just got a new
assignment sniper duty no btsu you're no
assassin
what you want to be a sniper now
pretty sure you need depth perception
for that gig wouldn't work even if you
had a robo-eye i've seen you in the
field you like getting your hands dirty
no i don't
but i'm not afraid to do what's
necessary you ready to work directly for
the president for your country
honey what's funny you just promoted me
to my old job
the division was activated by the
president but as soon as they went
against him and your ai forgot to update
the line of succession
you stopped working for the president
the way i see it you and the rogues
we've recruited are the only agents
still on mission
but that doesn't mean i have to like it
or you
barton made it official by giving faye a
position within the btsu ranks
her first job to guard president ellis
but this is where things started to
become a little more difficult than he'd
expected
the rogue agents they had introduced to
barden weren't exactly what you'd call
low maintenance
bringing them on board came at a
considerable cost and they were proving
to be somewhat challenging to work
well with shafer you made the deadline
i'm a man of my word for now
i need another delivery you know you're
not my only operator i know
but i'm your best
and if you want to keep me happy you'll
find a way to get a delivery of tear gas
to judiciary square
the sooner the better whatever you need
wraith
i aim to please that's my good boy
i knew you wouldn't let me down
get a crew together supply or combat
supply
got a new contact needs to prove himself
oh [ __ ] we're getting helicopter drones
no i didn't ask for anything that bad
[ __ ] too bad i could do some real damage
with one of those yeah pretty sure you
just get high and blow up another safe
house
but obliged wraith's request
he knew she had substantial influence
over the hyenas
and he needed them
they had a part to play in the upcoming
op
unfortunately wraith knew this and had
no problem testing how fast she could
push things to get what she wanted
what can i do for you now you can get
that tone out of your voice
what can i do for you wraith you got an
eta on my delivery should have
everything ready for your deadline
tomorrow good boy you sure you don't
need anything else
just the tear gas
when you said you were going to test me
i expected a test
you're still being tested
you haven't made the delivery yet
i value punctuality i'm always on time
we'll see
dusk contacted baden and explained the
situation that her and the true sons
were in
supplies were critically low and they
didn't have enough weapons to go around
barton agreed to the request of
assistance and made a deal where they
would work together
need an emergency supply drop what kind
weapons or rations yes
airdrop or do you need a delivery
whatever gets my men fed and armed by
tomorrow you got enough ammo to take on
hostiles one and two squads then it gets
dicey i can arrange an airdrop and send
coordinates have your team there in two
hours thanks shafer no problem dusk
shaffer how can i help you dusk wanna
let you know we got the supply drive
glad to hear it my boys are fed and
armed and ready to fight glad to hear it
what do you need wanted to set up a meet
what for i like to know who i'm working
with
i always find a face-to-face tells you
so much more than a voice on the radio
fair enough whenever you're free come
meet me in southwest i've got a safe
house there
looking forward to meeting you sounds
good looking forward to meeting you too
dusk
however this was all getting a bit much
his budget was being strained and
resources stretched then
barton started questioning whether these
rogue agents were even worth all of this
hassle and if they could even be trusted
he contacted faye to discuss his
concerns
faye this is schaefer i'm worried this
op is getting a little expensive
are we sure we want to spend all these
resources on the hyenas and the true
suns
dusk wants to meet up in person now
either she's got a crush on me
or this is a trap
how well do you really know these people
we're working with
unable to get hold of faye he decided to
take a step back and assess the
situation while dealing with other
pressing matters
but it was during this time that the
rogue agents started to feel neglected
went to the mate but you weren't there
what happened sorry i had to handle
something in dc you're the one who
wanted to meet and you stand me up i
didn't mean to disrespect you i should
have called but these comms aren't the
most secure and i didn't want to give
away your location that's okay shafer
this time you come to me it's too much
of a pain in the ass for me to get off
the island name the time and place i'll
be there once you land in two bridges
ping me and allison coordinates
what is it belfry you working with
schaefer yeah you know i am
what do you think of him oh
very professional you've been getting
your deliveries yeah on time and in full
[ __ ] you're not
no oh
guess he likes me better than you
dusk what is it belfry what do you think
of schaefer you like working with him
he's my [ __ ] what's not to like you
getting your deliveries yeah he saved my
ass last week with a ration supply drop
[ __ ]
he blowing you off he's not responding
to my calls maybe he realized your crazy
ass was a lost cause and cut his losses
[Laughter]
thanks dusk hope he cuts you too
schaefer this is belfree come in
what can i do for you
we're running low on munitions
incendiaries and rations we need a
delivery yesterday i can get an airdrop
put together for you in two hours have
something to take care of first just
need a drop zone west end i have a
recovery team based there perfect i'll
put it together hold tight the supply
drop will be there soon don't leave me
hanging again i wouldn't do that you can
trust me
and as every parent knows when the kids
feel neglected they start to play up
i don't know if you're new to this whole
comms thing
but
you should really be using code or get
us more secure channels i've gotta work
with the tools at my disposal wraith
seems a bit reckless
makes me worry about you schaefer
sweet of you to worry you're sloppy
either you're trying to get yourself or
me killed
and if you're trying to get me killed
i hate to disappoint you but better men
have tried and failed raith i'm not
suicidal and i know that your position
with the hyenas allows us to operate
more freely in dc i see your value
i am not sloppy
but resources are limited and we all
have to make do with what we have
well done
you didn't yell at me
you had a reasonable answer for your way
of working and complimented me
well then
you passed the test
barton is a patient man who had no
problem staying composed as he has dealt
with many challenging situations in his
career but he was starting to doubt
whether he could work with these people
unable to get in contact with faye he
talks to someone by the name of natalia
sokolova
natalia i'm not sure about this op they
wanted black tusk to collaborate with
the government
this is phase chance to prove her agents
are worthy
and our chance to keep my business
partners happy i think the only thing
she's proving is a division really
needed a better screening process you
brought her in
her failures are yours
fix it
i do not tolerate
failure i understand
it isn't clear who natalya is to barden
but she's certainly the one calling the
shots
she could be someone further at the
chain within the black tusk or maybe
even the main contact for the
organization that has employed them
biden instructed shade to wreak havoc on
the division in new york city
she set to work attacking multiple sites
in the financial district civic center
and two bridges
while wraith focused on the northeastern
side of dc including downtown west
downtown east federal triangle and
judiciary square
dusk made moves in southeastern dc
capturing multiple sites of value in
east mall southwest and capitol hill
and belfry directed his efforts towards
the west side of dc including the
districts of constitution hall foggy
bottom and west end but also new york's
coney island
one by one the division was able to
locate the rogue agents in lower
manhattan and dc
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
take them down
but this did include the assistance from
an unlikely foe
in each instance when finally able to
detect the location of the rogue agents
a hunter would appear
interestingly he didn't seem to be
focused solely on the division agents he
was hostile to both sides of the
conflict
regardless having eliminated his rogue
agents barton schaefer eventually made
his location known
he was on coney island
division agents had to navigate their
way through the amusement park which was
riddled with rikers
yet a familiar face kept making an
appearance
the hunter that agents have met time and
time again while disposing of baden's
rogues was also there
and this hunter was taking down rikers
faster than the agents were able to
progress through the park whenever they
would get close he would vanish
over the comms barton could be heard
telling the hunter to quit playing
around and kill the agents
and this is where the division met face
to face with the hunter that had been
following them throughout this operation
after a long dare i said couple of
attempts even the agents managed to take
down the hunter
biden updated natalya sokolova she
inquired of the hunter asset and when
biden informed her that had been
eliminated she ordered him to clean up
his mess and finish the job
barden instructed his group of elite
btsu operators to assemble and prepare
for the fast approaching division agents
but the agents made short work of them
and within no time at all baden's guards
were quickly disposed of
in a final offensive push baden took the
fight to the agents and although he was
strong and put up a formidable
resistance they eventually managed to
take him down
biden was critically injured but not
killed
a halo was sent in to retrieve him where
he would be brought back to health and
then questioned on his knowledge around
the black tusk and the organization who
had employed them
manhunt season 4 is now open and for the
first target agents are tasked with
locating bridget douglas codename viper
viper brings some interesting additions
to the story including the first
confirmed black tusk recruitment from
outside of the us military and a
possible link to other waves of division
agents that are yet to be activated
viper is the only child of charles
douglas the co-founder of a military
equipment company
she grew up on a secluded luxurious
estate in the scottish highlands
after graduating from university viper
completed an eight-year stint in the sas
before taking a position in her father's
company douglas and harding as a
logistics and supply specialist
however when the dollar flu outbreak hit
she was immediately contacted by the
black tusk yet this was after she was
recruited by the strategic homeland
division
completely disregarding her father's
opposition to the idea she joined up the
btsu shortly after
fast forward a few months feylau has
sided with schaefer and the btsu
she was inducted into the group meeting
several prominent members and viper was
among them
that's impressive
logistics and supply specialist not that
impressive you shouldn't do that
do what sell yourself short you are
impressive
you didn't have to join the services
rich girl like you had other options
just because my father has money it
doesn't mean i'm some spoiled rich girl
i can take care of myself your record
proves that
you joined the black tusk in december
that's correct before you were activated
i was never activated
guess they're still saving some of us
for the real end times does schaefer
know your division he never asked and i
didn't think it was worth bringing up
until it was a problem smart
i like smart women
me too
being that fey lau was the acting
division commander in new york she would
have had access to highly confidential
intel and was aware of viper's
recruitment into the division
viper was keeping this information from
schaefer and she chose to hold this
information from him unless approached
about it
she had spent her whole life having
people assume that she has it easy
everything given to her on a silver
platter and that she had no idea of the
stresses and complications that the
average person faced but through issues
with her father in their earlier years
she did her utmost to separate herself
from the privileged lifestyle and carve
her own path and this just happened to
be in a direction that her father
wouldn't approve of which probably only
made the path that much more appealing
following the outbreak charles douglas
can be seen talking to his business
partner john harding
the 27 years we spend building dna have
you ever known me to be a paranoid
lunatic of course not but there is no
conspiracy charles
everyone's just preparing all this panic
will die down soon enough someone is
freezing us out
we supply militaries for god's sake
if we can't book factory time this
company is going down the path look
forget about this conspiracy theory of
yours there's no secret cabal trying to
freeze us out let's just focus on
sorting out this mess i swear something
big is happening fine think what you
want i don't have enough energy to fight
you on this right now
with the current state of washington dc
and the rest of america it was having an
effect on business
with the closing down of factories and
inadequate numbers to run them
charles was certain that there was
something going on that was targeting
dnh weapons manufacturing
however not long after this conversation
john harding would pass away due to
complications from influenza
as the situation continued to get worse
in dc charles eventually relocated to
the white house
where he is working and i use his term
very loosely as the range officer in the
shooting range
as a father charles was very hard on
viper
she found him a difficult man to please
who was constantly critical towards
everything she did and would often
downplay her achievements
this in turn resulted in her moving in
life directions that were against his
will
although this meant she was forced to
grow up to be strong and independent she
still bears the scars of a very critical
upbringing
viper doesn't think particularly highly
of herself and tends to be a little
insecure around her
abilities at the white house what kelso
said he's running a shooting range and
drinking dandelion coffee from a very
fancy espresso machine huh well that
sounds like my dad
he's doing great found a way to make
himself useful
he was lucky never caught the virus and
still has all his parts aside from the
dandelion instead of his regular copy
luak it sounds like his life hasn't
changed much
he's still in the lab getting people to
test his equipment and probably making
them feel really insecure about their
accuracy you miss him of course
but when something like this happens
you have to do what you think is right
i'm glad we each found something
even if he is actively making my life
harder
which
yeah that hasn't really changed much
either
leading up to the operation faye
discusses the role that viper will
role you don't play to lead your own
team i prefer to be in a support role
i get that
some people aren't cut out to make the
hard choices oh that's not what i'm
worried about what are you worried about
being responsible for my team's life
you'll make sacrifices to save them
no
that'll consider their deaths an
acceptable loss
we know what we signed up for we assume
this is a suicide mission if you make it
back home that's the unexpected outcome
you worried about survivor's guilt
can't be worried about something you
can't control and every mission i come
back from i never feel guilty not about
being the one that comes back
other [ __ ]
sure but never that i survived
viper isn't interested in leading a team
not because she's scared of the
responsibility more that she's worried
about treating them as expendable
in her career she was always aware of
what they were there for and that there
was a chance that they may never
returned
but in this situation the men she would
lead would be relying on her to keep
them alive
regardless faye pushed her out of her
comfort zone and assigned her a squad
how's it feel good
weird
i like being in charge but yeah it's
it's weird being the one people are
looking to for guidance
your team speaks highly of you viper
you're a natural leader likable kind
tough when you need to be they respect
you but aren't intimidated by you
cool that's hard to pull off
especially for a woman
thanks
i try not to be a [ __ ] i'm still
working on that one
to viper's surprise she was actually
quite suited to the task of leading a
team
she is a valuable and well respected
leader
when instructed to do so viper sit forth
executing her part in the operation
taking her band of btsu she started
creating havoc in the southern districts
of washington dc
multiple sites of interest were captured
in west potomac east mall southwest and
also the pentagon
one by one the division took back these
areas eliminating all black tusks who
engaged them
eventually they managed to catch up with
viper
although she put up a strong resistance
the agents managed to put a stop to her
activities and take her down
in turn removing fey lau's first
lieutenant from the field
it isn't clear what viper's part in this
operation was but through continuing to
hunt down the remainder of the
lieutenants phase plan and location
should hopefully become known
the latest target in the season 4
manhunt has confirmed a few suspicions
that have been discussed up until now
felix sokolov has been reunited with his
sister and he is thrilled to be able to
grow and work together in her newly
acquired empire
but does she share the same intentions
russian businessman alexei sokolov is
the founder and ceo of the hugely
successful international military
equipment manufacturer circle of concern
alexey had a daughter to an earlier
relationship that separated later for
unknown reasons
he later married an american woman and
eventually they had his first and only
son felix
as a family they decided to relocate to
his wife's country of birth the united
states but left behind his daughter to
keep the family business taking along
her name was natalia sokolova
[Music]
alexey was hard on felix and had high
hopes and expectations that he forced
upon him
as soon as he graduated from school
felix was told by his father that he
must enlist with the navy
while on deployment his father died
under suspicious circumstances and after
a lengthy court battle felix's mother
was eventually convicted of his murder
when his tour was over he moved on to
study medicine at john hopkins
university it was during this time that
he was recruited by the strategic
homeland division
but regardless sometime after completing
his study he was approached and
recruited by the black tusk
after her father's death and his
stepmother's conviction natalia reached
out to felix
she went on to fund her studies and
attempt to reunite with the brother that
she barely knew
when biden schaefer brought feylau on
board she met up with felix during her
induction
you were a good agent felix what made
you leave the division family
i get that
you lose someone my sister
the virus no
rikers
i couldn't keep her safe
budget cuts
well you'll never have that problem with
black dusk
natalia will get us anything we need
natalia my sister
she runs this entire operation
anything you need i can get it
you don't think it's weird she'd let you
work in the field
it's not the safest place for a kid like
you you've read my profile you know i've
served before
it's why the division recruited me
well that and i'm sure they got a family
discount on those knee pads you were
wearing when schaefer brought you in
it's unclear whether natalya's name and
involvement with the black tusk was a
surprise to faye or not but she didn't
seem overly convinced that natalia's
intentions towards felix were purely
about tight family bonds
you asking the other candidates this
much about their families only when it's
relevant so what else do you want to
know how close are you with your sister
not as close as i'd like
it's hard she grew up in russia i didn't
really get to know her until after our
father died that was what six or seven
years ago six
what does it matter nothing just that's
around the same time she started black
tusk
so oh nothing i'm just thinking out loud
it's interesting that your father dies
she reconnects or connects with you
she inherits the company and builds this
pmc it just seems like
never mind
i've seen conspiracies where they
probably don't exist my sister loves me
i'm sure she does when we lost our
father she was allowed to come from
russia for the funeral it's not that
hard to understand that in that moment
she was there to help me she put me
through school she got me this job
she saw how agents were dying and she
sacrificed her men to bring me in and
protect me
you don't do that if you don't care
about someone
felix wasn't having a bar of it he
refused to believe that natalia's help
was anything but family helping one
another
she offered him a role in the black tusk
after seeing how out of the depth the
division was
she rescued him from what was looking
like certain death
before the main operation faye talks to
felix about escorting a vip
castrol get your team ready got an
assignment nothing too big just need you
to escort a vip babysitting duty
seriously don't you have some grunts who
can do this trust me this escort is too
important to leave to a rookie well now
you've got my attention
given what we know about the black tusk
at this stage and who remains in their
ranks it's likely that this target is
president alice or someone of equally
high importance to them
so they needed the right person for the
job
leading up to the operation felix
discusses strategy with viper
you ready for this absolutely you don't
mind not knowing who the target is i
trust faye
and frankly she's right
we've had too many leaks
she's smart to keep this one close to
the best do you know who the target is
i've got my suspicions
but i'm not going to speculate i think
it's kelso okay sparky don't strain that
big brain of yours
being young and eager felix is keen to
get started on the op but expresses
confusion around the lack of intel
viper trusts fey and understands the
reasons behind the secrecy
unwilling to rock the boat felix accepts
this and continues with his preparation
when instructed to do so he set forth
executing his part in the operation
taking his band of btsu he started
capturing locations of interest in the
northeastern districts of washington dc
multiple sites were captured in downtown
east federal triangle and judiciary
square
however the division were hot on his
tail and were quickly able to put a stop
to his advancements
after taking back these sites they were
able to find his location
while phoenix put up a somewhat
unorthodox assault
[Music]
the division was eventually able to push
him back taking down his btsu guard and
eventually eliminating him in the
process
for the third target of the season 4
manhunt
we come up against a rogue agent going
for the call sign magnus
what information will we find towards
locating the division's second wave
acting commander felau
dustin xavier codename magnus grew up in
atlanta georgia
a true patriot at heart he went on to
join the us military to do his part in
fighting for and protecting his country
during his second tour in afghanistan
his unit was struck by an improvised
explosive device and they were ambushed
shortly after
after showing extraordinary heroism
during this incident he later received
the valorous unit award
it was at this point that he was
approached by the shd and recruited
shortly thereafter
however it wasn't long before he started
questioning how well prepared the
division was with their mission
or xavier or javier
xavier thanks it annoys me when people
don't know how to say lao but have no
problem with maguire mcmahon o'shea and
kavanaugh fisher schneider mueller might
have something to say about that your co
was german right very third generation
kept assisting his family was never
nazi's which you know
the more you protest the more likely you
are exactly that thing boys let's show
the lady what she's won
your unit in afghanistan
yeah
you got hit by an ied
it happens
any residual trauma just the normal
gotta make sure it wasn't for nothing
that's how they got me just in case we
need you to join us just in case most
likely you'll never be activated but
just in case
you survived the worst you could handle
this no one can handle this we're just
here to minimize the damage
and hope there's something left when
we're through
and if there isn't we will be the ones
to rebuild it
looking forward to working with you
magnus
he came to the conclusion that the
recruitment process was more about
getting numbers and ticking boxes rather
than being adequately prepared for such
an event to occur
and this was only further supported when
he witnessed the lack of equipment and
resources allocated to agents and how
hugely insufficient it was to handle the
crisis at hand
not long after his activation in
washington dc magnus was approached by
baden
you schaefer it
we're the same you're a patriot you
served your country same as me
we've seen what can happen when a weak
leader rises to power we have
and i know that we can't rely on the
government to save us
this thing moves too fast you have to be
agile the wheels of government rule too
slowly for something like this they're
trying to use a scalpel when what we
need is a sledgehammer i can be that
hammer
magnus immediately recognized an
individual with the same drive and
objectives as himself
someone who only wanted what was best
for the country
so he would go on to join with the black
tusk
magnus would later be assigned to
feylau's unit of rogue agents but his
demeanor didn't exactly have him fitting
in with the rest of the team
magnus sub viper
gross what i just said sup yeah i know
what sup means hey hey you don't mean
nothing unless you wanted to mean
something gross hey you don't have to be
like that and you don't have to be a
disgusting human being but here we are
i hope you get eclipsed
that's [ __ ] up i just said sup and you
wish that keener [ __ ] on me you're cold
viper i thought we were friends
being a soldier was all he knew he was
just there to do a job and work with the
side that he believed had the country's
best interests at heart
he wasn't there to prove himself he
hadn't been impacted by the failure of
the government or the shd
he hadn't witnessed tragedy or lost
anyone close to him as a result
he simply found a team that he saw was
more aligned with his goals and were
better equipped to handle it
however some of the ways he approached
certain aspects of the organization
wasn't necessarily appreciated by his
colleagues
he just couldn't seem to comprehend that
he wasn't in the military anymore and
his new comrades from vastly different
backgrounds didn't seem to be overly
fond of his banter and the ideas that he
brought to the table
i don't know why you keep pitching me
your dumbass ideas my ideas aren't dumb
who better than the people in the field
the ones using the gear to tell you what
they want and need out of the gear
fine okay
so like stay with me
think about it think about what give me
a second
okay
picture it you're out in the field
you've got hostiles on your right and
left yeah so it's a tuesday i see an
opportunity to run and slide into cover
but there's mud yeah some are in dc lots
of mud got it and you've only got one
pair of pants so what do you want what
if your knee pads had quick depletion in
hip guards
you want my sister to make knee pads
that have quick deploy sliding shin and
hip guards
so you don't have to wash mud off your
pants yeah think how awesome that would
be
yeah
i'm not calling her for that
when the time came magnus set forth
executing his part in the operation
taking his unit of btsu he started
capturing locations of interest in the
western districts of washington dc
multiple sites were captured in downtown
west constitution hall and east end
but as has happened time and time again
the division were there to stop the
rogue advances
the shd were able to quickly and
efficiently remove any trace of his
movements in dc
and eventually caught up to him
taken by surprise he put up a valiant
fight but was no match for the agents
cersei is the rogue agent credited with
converting fey lau over to the black
tusk
so with this in mind what more can she
add to the story behind the former
second wave commander going rogue
alicia coswald callsign cersei grew up
in brooklyn new york
although she didn't come from money she
more than made up for it with
determination and dedication
cersei is a confident proud american
citizen with an optimistic and positive
attitude towards everything she sets her
mind to
after doing a tour in the army she took
advantage of the gi bill a law that was
introduced in 1944 that helps veterans
with the funding towards education
including college graduate school and
other training programs
it was during this time that she was
approached and then recruited by the
division
after graduating college cersei went on
to teach english as a high school
teacher and it was around this time that
the dollar flew was first released into
new york city
it wasn't long after she was activated
that she realized that the division was
hopelessly unprepared for the situation
they were facing
as a strong patriotic individual she
believed that the shd didn't have what
it took to get the country through these
difficult times
cersei was eventually approached by the
black tusk
having already lost faith in the
division it didn't take much convincing
to bring her over to this side
sometime after the black tusk made
themselves known to the division and
invaded washington dc
cersei was captured by agent feylau
i know you're working with someone
careful
faye you don't want to make isaac upset
he hit me like that again he'll think
you've gone rogue you teamed up with the
jtf we do what we have to you got a
concussion you're the one who isn't
thinking straight
what's your mission agent to save what
remains to ensure survival
that we live on that when we finally get
back on our feet there is something left
to stand on cool story faye and how's
that working out for you it's hard
but we're stable sure for now
what about next week
or the week after
or when you haven't had a sarah delivery
for months and the medicine runs out and
the people who work together so well
right now turn on one another what are
you gonna do then faye we will adapt we
will work together and find a way to
move forward and when they steal your
tech and turn your turrets against you
what'll you do then faye what i have to
alicia i'm doing the same
you're not there yet but you'll see
we're the same i'm not like you
i'm not a traitor i'm not a traitor
i'm effective
i can see where this is going and who
can actually make a change
you'll figure it out eventually
or you'll die
either way my boys will find me soon
enough and then you'll need to make a
choice
what choice is that
to let me go
or see if you're good enough to take on
my team
who are you working with still haven't
figured it out
thought you were better than this i just
want to confirm it you scared never
you should be we took out the lmb i'm
not afraid of black tusk so you are as
smart as you pretend to be i'm a lot of
things you shouldn't underestimate me
now tell me about your first meeting
with schaefer how do you know about
schaefer
susie was surprised to learn that faye
knew of baden schaefer
had she too been approached by him were
they still in contact
regardless faye eventually agreed to
release her
cersei would regroup with the black tusk
although she was the one being
interrogated
cersei had learned a lot from their
interactions
she sensed a certain vulnerability a
degree of doubt and phase eyes
cersei took to schaefer about the
potential of a new valuable asset
towards the black tusk cause
she get anything out of you nothing we
didn't want her to she gonna be a
problem pretty sure she's an asset you
think she's ready she's desperate a
little push and she's one of us is that
a good idea no one has better access to
the division than faye we bring her to
our side we'll know where all the bodies
are buried then it's just a matter of
time before they fall and we rise
although apprehensive about the idea
schaefer takes cersei's feedback on
board and proceeds with plans to entice
fey over to this side
some time has passed
the division has managed to locate and
eliminate kinase rogue agents and
eventually the man himself
and this is when it was made known that
feylau herself has gone rogue
i can't believe we're working together
again ah
sorry about the black site i get it you
didn't know what this was you're right i
had no idea what this was
i'm starting to understand though
i'm glad you signed on
i always liked you faye i like you too
alicia
use my call sign cersei makes it less
weird
alicia's too personal
reminds me of life before this [ __ ] fair
enough
you want a call sign for this op no
it's better if i remember where i came
from
cersei confides in fey welcoming her to
the team with open arms forgiving her
for a lack of understanding from the
earlier interactions
but it wasn't long before schaefer gave
faye her own team to work with
and one of the first assignments she
gave out to cersei was to get the
location and schedule of president ellis
what do you need just a location and
schedule should be a piece of cake for
you cersei whose location and schedule
do you need
chicken hawk
that's need to know faye you know that
i need to know what do you want it for
just need to make sure that he's not in
any danger
getting rumblings about transports and
mobile units outside of dc going through
maryland just want to confirm that
chicken hawks not in any danger
although suspicious of her reasoning
cersei gets her the information
shafer really knows how to pick them hey
he picked me we're different his
original squad complete fuck-ups you're
not wrong how do you lose the pentagon
how do you lose a bioreactor you know i
i still can't tell if it's incompetence
or a leak a leak someone on the inside
leaking intel to the division why would
you say something like that makes more
sense than why we're losing the
antivirals and random agents getting
lucky wyvern wasn't stable on the best
of days for an elite squad our comms
should be secure we shouldn't be having
these leaks isaac's good but he's not
that good there's no way that we should
be compromised like this maybe someone
programmed a back door into our comms
relay just pumping intercepted radio to
some data analyst in a basement under
the lincoln memorial makes sense viper i
was kidding
jesus you need to get laid you're wound
too tight you might be right
but i wouldn't let any of these chuckle
[ __ ] touch me
they're not exactly my type
acknowledging the failings of schaefer's
original squad susie proclaims that this
time is different and when the time came
she set forth executing her part in the
operation
taking a unit of btsu she started
capturing locations of interest in
southern manhattan
multiple sites were captured in battery
park the financial district civic centre
and two bridges
but much like the many rogue agents the
division have come across in the past
they were able to stop the rogue
advances
the shd were able to quickly and
efficiently remove any trace of her
movements in new york and eventually
caught up to her
cersei put up a tough fight
in fact it took the agents a couple more
attempts than i
they would ever like to admit to
however in the end she was no match for
them and was ultimately killed in the
fight
feylau was one of the division's most
trusted agents
however her mission to avenge the death
of her sister and rid the world of aaron
kina led her to going rogue and joining
the black tusk
but why did she choose to take this path
and betray the shd and her fellow agents
feylau is a second generation chinese
american
when she was only 17 years old she
tragically lost both of her parents in a
car accident resulting in her being
tasked with raising her younger sister
heather on her own
records state that this changed her
certain behavioral traits including
integrity accountability empathy
resilience vision and influence were
enhanced
resulting in strong leadership traits
that would assist her in the years to
come
however this also came at the expense of
her ability to gain and manage personal
relationships
while attending city college faye joined
the school's reserve offices training
corps
she used this to help further progress
her career
after a number of positions within
military intelligence faye was
eventually admitted into the national
security agency where she worked as a
part of the support staff for the
director of national intelligence
after the presidential director 51 was
signed faye relocated to the newly
formed strategic homeland division as a
senior field officer
she would be reporting directly to the
north eastern section division commander
lewis chang
shortly after the first wave of division
agents disappeared president waller
activated a second wave of agents into
new york city and ordered commander
chang to personally lead the operations
fey was activated to serve as chang's
second in command
but as the helicopter was approaching
its destination to pick up faye and the
remaining agents of the second wave it
was shot down and destroyed killing
commander chang and seriously wounding
fae
her injuries meant that she had to be
removed from field work
but as feylau was now the most senior
agent in the city she continued to serve
as the acting division commander
from here she was the primary contact
and strategic support for all remaining
second wave division agents in new york
months pass the division have made vast
steps in regaining control of new york
all major hostile faction leaders have
been killed and a number of parts of the
city were starting to rebuild
furthermore intel suggests that the
first wave rogue agents have left the
city along with their leader aaron kina
more months pass
the division's network was taken down
and protocol dictated that all available
agents must get to washington dc as soon
as possible but faye made the choice to
stay in new york to stop them from
losing the foothold they've gained over
the months prior
there is an attack on the southern
manhattan jtf outpost at city hall
agents from dc are sent to investigate
they learn that the attack was
orchestrated by the rogue agent arankina
it has now been over eight months since
the majority of the division agents
headed to dc and faye had finally
recovered from her injuries
however something else was coming and
this would see faye's whole world come
crashing down
a settlement in hell's kitchen district
has been attacked by rikers
with near to no defensive systems and a
dwindling amount of jtf to properly
guard and patrol the facilities there
were massive casualties
including fei's sister
nevertheless with help from the division
agents from dc she continues the hunt
for aaron kina
it was around this time that faye
manages to capture a rogue agent who
just happens to be working for the black
tusk
agent alicia coswell otherwise known as
cersei
the following weeks would see the
division locating and eliminating kena's
rogue agents and eventually the man
himself
but even more shocking was the
revelation from new york's number one
agent
schaefer do you read
listening
fall back
keener's dead
but he's activated the network
what's the damage
cornell's watch is collating the data
looks like it's all of them
[ __ ] more rogue agents just we [ __ ]
need
it's perfect
this will bring the division to its
knees
and that's when we'll end them
once and for all
although still apprehensive of the
decision to join up with the black tusk
faye meets up with baden schaefer to
discuss plans going forward
how's it feel
comfortable
lacks personality though
easier to spot a friendly in the field
the uniform doesn't guarantee you're a
friendly
fair enough
i like your style now no [ __ ] i
think you'll fit in well here
me too do i get to build my team are you
testing me out with an established squad
are you worried about getting hazed i've
had to break into boys clubs before
i know how you like to test people
finish this up and we'll talk about
building your own squad
copy that
over time schaefer was eventually hunted
down by her former colleagues and
captured
faye took little time in organizing a
meeting with president ellis
this is our chance
to shape history
i couldn't agree more mr president you
said it yourself
somebody has to step up i'm willing to
take on that challenge if we're going to
get this country back on track
we have to be willing to do things that
won't be
popular
i know that you and shaffer had a rather
contentious relationship
i hope our collaboration will be more
efficient
i look forward to meeting you in person
that can be arranged
excellent
see you soon mr president
what an [ __ ]
after finding out else's whereabouts and
schedule fae caught up with them at camp
white oak
and when the time came without
hesitation she gunned him down where he
stood
meeting adjourned
mr president
it's done
at this point in time division agents
were already hot on a trail but she had
already rang through announcing that it
was a division that had taken the
president out so time was of the essence
they needed to catch up with her before
they too were announced as rogue
chasing her through the compound they
eventually caught up with her in the
area that alice himself had once escaped
their grasp
but this time they were prepared
disabling the helicopter faye was forced
to engage the agents head-on
after a short fight the division was
able to eliminate her supporting btsu
forces
although faye certainly brought the
fight the shd agents had no problem
bringing the full force of their
vengeance to the party
let's face it i haven't heard from a
single person that wouldn't agree that
this was a disappointing end to the
manhunt
but based on the trailer and the sudden
announcement from massive that this was
to be the last update to the division 2
i think that this isn't the last we're
going to hear of phelau
i legitimately believe that we were
supposed to capture fae similar to what
we did with schaefer
but due to the apparent unexpected
decision to extend the division over the
next year or two they potentially cut
the final cinematic to be expanded on
later
this could also be further supported by
the fact that isaac never said anything
of substance when she was dropped
but if theo taught us anything isaac can
be easily manipulated so who knows
however for now let's look at the facts
that have been presented to us in game
faye lost his sister due to an adequate
jtf resource to look after the
settlements
faye captures and interrogates cersei
aaron keener is killed followed shortly
after with faye being found out as rogue
barton schaefer is captured by the
division
faye locates president ellis and
executes him blaming it on the division
faye is found and potentially captured
by the division
then there is the last comms that we
received from this manhunt that leads to
the idea that fey is working as an
undercover rogue agent
i know
you hate me you never trusted me you
probably never liked me and only
moderately tolerated me
it's okay
that's okay
we didn't have to be friends
and i know you probably think i'm a
[ __ ] that you would never actually say
that that's my face at least
i think the reason we never really got
along is we're too similar
we're stubborn we care too much and
frankly we're both pretty guarded people
we've both lost people and we didn't
deal with that as well as we could have
i guess but
i hope that when i'm done you'll
understand why i did what i had to do
i don't expect you to agree with it but
i hope you understand
i'm not sorry i went down like this but
i'm sorry i couldn't tell you why
hey roy
this is hard
for me
this is probably the hardest thing i've
ever had to do
you trusted me and i loved you for that
it broke my heart having to keep secrets
like this from you but i knew
i knew if i told you what i was planning
you would try to stop me
and if you tried to stop me
there's no way i could have gone through
with any of it
there's no way i could have interrogated
alicia or met shafer or gone with him
i had to do this roy i had to
we were losing we lost the authority we
lost the trust of the people we were
trying to protect without trust we have
nothing
it doesn't matter how many good or bad
things we do if no one trusts you to get
the job done
and with schaefer and ellis we lost the
legitimacy we lost the ability to say we
are on mission
hell the only one who agreed we were
still on mission was isaac
i knew what i had to do
all i needed was access and
i couldn't get that unless i joined them
or at least unless i could make them
believe i joined them
i'm sorry i couldn't tell you why
i'm sorry i had to break your trust like
that
but i hope i i pray
you'll forgive me someday
if you don't
i might have to come hot your ass until
you do
loud
though if this is true and she is simply
going through all of this to take down
the black tusk asset prison ellis why
did she blame his death on the division
this leads me into two different trains
of thought
alice is the one responsible for having
the jtf abandoned the quarantine zone
not long after the initial outbreak
this in turn led to many division agents
going rogue with one notable agent in
particular aaron kina
faye blames kina for his part in the
death of her sister and alice's part in
putting keener in that position
the division is the last organization
with any ties to the old government
given them claimed to determine what's
right and wrong
it's no secret that faye isn't a fan of
the way that isaac operates
but considering everything that's
happened perhaps faye has finally lost
hope in the government in the shd too
she has come to the conclusion that this
strategic homeland division is a failed
initiative and that with all the freedom
they are given they still don't have
enough wriggle room under the guidance
of isaac to do what is needed
i don't necessarily think she believes
the black task of the answer but now
that schaefer has been captured she
decided to seize the opportunity and
kill two birds with one stone
she would execute alice and bring down
the shd
as witnessed in warlord of new york at
the haven settlement trust in the
division is already pretty low the
general public is sick of watching these
agents do what they want and eventually
turning rogue and working against them
with faye blaming the death on the
division that should be enough to push
the remaining settlements over the edge
and without the support of the people
the agency would collapse
this would basically put the division
agents in a position of becoming rogue
agents
whether isaac has flagged them as rogue
or not is redundant in the eyes of the
people they are no longer allies put in
place to save what remains
however i don't think having each of the
agents hunted down and killed is what
faye actually wants
this is likely just a side effect of
what she's done
she may have just deemed this as
acceptable collateral damage in her
mission of putting the final nail in the
coffin for the old us government and the
shd
in fact maybe she was hoping that they
would regroup with her later on no
longer under the shd control
[Music]
alternatively the second and probably my
preferred direction
faye hasn't lost hope in the government
and she still strongly believes in the
division's mission of saving what
remains
but over time watching this determined
and well-funded new enemy and the
remaining agents around her either being
killed or turning rogue joining the
black tusk ranks she's come to the
conclusion that they are fighting a
losing battle
the only one left in the government is
corrupt and has joined the other side
the chain of command is already broken
it was up to her to take him down before
he was used to bring the general
populace over to their side
faye would go undercover and eliminate
ellis after gaining their trust
she had to do this alone firstly she
didn't know who she could trust anymore
and those she could like benitez
wouldn't allow her to do this on her own
but she had already lost enough loved
ones and didn't want to be responsible
for more of their deaths on her hands
the reason she blamed alice's death on
the division agents was to keep her
cover from being blown
after all schaefer had already been
captured but natalya sokolova was still
out there and while she was still around
the black tusks are a threat to the
country
yes this means that the division has now
been burned but as she had seen them as
only losing ground to this invading
force it was a sacrifice she had to make
on top of this given that they are now
rogue agents she may be able to bring
more of them undercover into the btsu to
help in her mission especially once
benitez and rhodes receive her message
fellow decided that it was up to her to
do what no division agent was able to
and that the only way to do this was to
go rogue join up the black tusk and take
ellis and the rest of his leadership
down from the inside
i'm not gonna lie it feels a bit lazy
making compilation videos but people
keep saying they'd rather watch a string
of videos from me than one offs
youtube obviously already has a playlist
feature but from what i can tell from
the analytics no one seems to use them
i almost did a compilation for the whole
of the division 2 story but that would
have been over 10 hours long plus a lot
of the videos are somewhat obsolete as
the story has progressed
anyway i hope you found this informative
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]